[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the chargers head coach the two in
one chargers fresh off the win against
the kansas city chiefs brandon staley
back on the program coach
congratulations did you watch monday
night football
i took a peek at it not not very much of
it but took a peek at it
but if that's uh afc games afc teams
would you be more apt to be watching
them
i kind of believe in the power of focus
i have a difficult time game planning
while a ball game's going on so
one of my best friends is the d
coordinator for philly so i was taking a
peek at it just for a second and you
know we played dallas so kind of wanted
to see how that team looked and
so i took a peek at it but i can't i'm
not i'm not big during the game planning
process of uh doing two things at once
okay you just played dallas dallas picks
up the win what what is it uh that you
saw with dallas like what impressed you
well i played them the year before when
i was with the rams and i know that when
we played them that first game of the
2020 season i just felt like it was a
really complete offense
because they have uh you know a 40
million dollar quarterback who's
outstanding
uh they have a line you know with two
really all decade type players and zach
martin and tyron smith and then you talk
about their runners uh and their
receivers i mean you got zeke pollard uh
amari cooper cd lamb michael gallup and
i love i'm a big fan of jarwin and
schultz i think they're just they're
really complete offense and that's what
i saw this year and i felt like you know
we hung tough for some this year with
the chargers and i felt like gave
ourselves a chance against that team
it's just a really difficult team to
defend and i felt like holding them to
20. you know we were proud of that we
can certainly play better for sure um
but uh that's just it's a really
complete offense and you're seeing it
with the way they score the ball balance
run in the pass game and they've got a
quarterback that can make a lot happen
so they're a tough cover for sure
patrick mahomes was held to less than
six yards per attempt against the
chargers that's the third lowest yards
per attempt in a single game in his
career
what did you make him do that he didn't
want to do
i think that was dan that was certainly
the story line in the game for me
defensively as we wanted to put a roof
over the coverages they're a knockout
team and and they normally knock you out
early uh and they do it in the deep part
of the field now when you say roof over
the coverage
layman's terms
yeah meaning you're not going deep
against us
um and we're we're gonna be aware
we're gonna catch you when you're
running deep we're going to have people
waiting on you in a lot of different
ways what we try to do is
have a variety of coverage systems that
collect people in the deep part of the
field and when you have
all those guys who can get deep like
they have with with tyrique and kelsey
and and hardman uh pringle all those
guys can get deep so and and they got a
quarterback that can hit you deep okay
and and a lot of times it's all outside
the rhythm and timing of the play and so
um to defend them dan in the passing
game you have to have your pass rush and
your pass coverage connected and that's
what i was most proud of in the game um
because you know this guy's a truly
unique player and he's playing with some
unique players so it takes a team effort
on defense and i felt like we played uh
the way we needed to on on sunday
what's more important if i if i said you
had to pick offense or defense going
into a game with kansas city
is it more important that your offense
is great or your defense is great if you
had to pick one of the two
if you have to pick one damage your
offense because historically this guy
doesn't get held
under 24 points very much you know
that's what the data tells you is that
he's going to score
and so i think um you know it's it's
like defending golden state
you can't just expect this to be an old
school eastern conference final new york
knicks chicago bulls 8379 slugfest it's
just it's not going to be played that
way um you you have to be able to score
the ball and i felt like that's what
gave us a chance in the game was we were
four out of five touchdowns in the red
area um you know you got to be
of that mindset to score the football
and so we're fortunate that we also have
a complete offense um you know led by a
tremendous quarterback and we've got
really good skill players and our
offensive line is really coming together
so uh when you play against that team
you got to be able to score
if somebody hadn't seen justin herbert
play how would you describe
that
i think he makes playing quarterback
look effortless i think that there's a
lot
that he the way he plays or he's just
really really smooth where you don't
even realize what's
you know unfolding before your eyes like
some of the throws that he's able to
make some of the plays he's able to make
he really makes it look easy
um
he's just a really smooth player like
just his stroke like the way he throws
the football it's just it's such an
effortless stroke it doesn't look like
he's straining you know he had this
throw against the cowboys it's a field
hash
kind of two deep zone beater hey hey i'm
gonna keep my eyes in the middle and
then i'm going to unpack really like a
60-plus yard throw on the sideline to
keenan
and just the velocity of that throw
is just really unique uh the way he can
play the game and i think
the other thing dan about him is he's
really instinctive for the position you
know he plays the game with tremendous
instincts on game day like he is truly
at his best on game day because he can
see the field uh he can see the field he
can feel the rush and he's got um those
instincts where he's making the right
decision
a lot of the time and um and that's
really special and and then you know
he's just one of the guys too like if
you see the way
his teammates play around him i think
you can tell a lot about a quarterback
by how his teammates respond to him
on both sides of the ball
and if you look at that game on sunday
the way our team feels about him uh i
think tells you a lot of of who he is as
a person and as a competitor do you
sometimes forget that he's played
20 some games in his career like that
that he's a kid out there
he can make you feel that way for sure
he can make you feel like you're
around a much wiser older player um with
how he is able to absorb and process and
and then apply you know he can he just
has that um capacity you know i like
that word like he has that capacity uh
but at the same time you do realize that
he's at the beginning and you know
myself and joe lombardi shane day uh
we're trying to dive into his game all
the time because there's so many areas
where he can improve and
and what's exciting is that he loves to
improve he loves the work he loves that
that that process to improve and you
know we're still at the beginning with
him but i know that uh on sunday um he
was pick reason why we won that game
he's brandon staley the chargers head
coach they got the raiders on monday
night and coach of course went to the
university of dayton uh started two
years i believe at quarterback going uh
16 and five is that right do you think
is that your one loss record coach 16
and five i remember all five losses
that's for sure okay but do you ever sit
down with justin herbert and you both
reminisce about your college days like
you tell him this is what i used to do
at the university of dayton
i don't go back to my quarterbacking
days too often i'm a lot more
impressed by uh his quarterbacking
status and we try to keep that the main
focus
and uh i definitely wouldn't want him to
create any any bad habits by watching my
game tape okay but what if i had a head
coaching quarterback challenge
who would who would be the best head
coach
well i think i i you know i think justin
and i i take justin i to the game versus
versus anybody no just just the head
coaches it's just you versus
oh okay i thought you meant quarterback
cliff kingsbury frank reich
yeah i mean you're talking about you
know
you're talking about some pretty
impressive uh names there i i don't know
if i i would be able to uh to take you
know i i certainly got confidence in
myself i think it would depend on the
competition for sure um
but uh well you gotta be better than
gruden right
i think that's safe to say
wait that's that's bulletin board
material here for this monday night game
no no no i i was uh i was a freshman in
college when they when they won the
super bowl and he came to speak at ud he
was doing is his book tour so uh you
know uh he certainly accomplished a lot
more as an nfl coach tonight
what were you doing five years ago this
weekend
five years ago i was it i was at carroll
uh you know we were i think we just so
john carroll john carroll yeah outside
of cleveland
yeah yeah and you you played heidelberg
yeah yeah we and that was a listen
before i got to carol they got
absolutely smoked by this team this kind
of was like a rugged tough
really have a lot of respect for this
football team they've had a lot of nfl
guys come out of there
and you know i think they lost like
42-14 the year before tommy and i got
there and
that was it that was a rivalry that we
really had to turn around and they
always played us tough and that was a
that was a big game and that 2016 season
kind of our best season that magical
season that we had and uh we had a good
game plan they had a really good runner
and um really good receiver who ended up
going to the nfl dante died so we ended
up kind of taking him out of the game
and uh so that's what i was doing five
years ago that's amazing now did coach
schuler go to john carroll
yeah coach schull is the most famous uh
but then you add you know dayton had
john gruden
uh jerry found some chuck noll
yeah oh yeah coach noll yeah i don't
know how many schools have head coaches
who won a super bowl and and dayton's
got two and then you'll be the third
well you're too kind well i i coached
with you know the guy that brought me
into the nfl is john fox and foxy means
so much to me i certainly wouldn't be
here without him and he coached for
chuck noll and he's one of those guys
that you know man i wish i could have
met him because just the the stories
that people have about him and how he
led that football team and uh just a lot
of the coaches that have kind of come
out of there you know tony dungy and all
these amazing coaches like i'm a proud
ud i'm i'm proud to share that that ud
alumni with with coach nolan and john
for sure great to talk to you again
coach congratulations on the win good
luck monday night against uh john gruden
and company
thanks a lot dan
brandon staley you know what i saw
what's interesting with the the chargers
they were aggressive they were
aggressive late in the game they went
forward on fourth and nine
and you have to do that with kansas city